here to help us do just that is kelly
namira of wellness by kelly thank you so
much for being here thank you again for
having me i'm so excited to be back i
have to say i love following you on
social media because you always share so
much into your personal life but you
give such great tips whether it's for
your diet or just mentally getting there
whatever it may be and let's talk about
the new year you're a mom about to be a
mom of two congrats thank you so it's
overwhelming and it's kind of just like
where do you even start with the new
year so what are some of your tips
especially for the moms out there i
think that whether we're a mom or not if
we're just like a busy woman in general
which i know you are um i think that
having this ability to do it in a really
small sustainable way rather than saying
okay it's a new year i'm going to change
all my habits overnight because that
just doesn't stay
sustainable it's not we can't keep it
consistent so if we can build those
habits in a really small way like having
a few moves that we can do for 15
minutes
or changing our morning you know waffles
to a green smoothie really small things
make the biggest difference over oh in a
consistent way over a long amount of
time and that's better to just start
small so you don't feel overwhelmed and
we all have so much going on and it
seems like okay we have to make these
big plans and if we don't achieve them
we failed but i really love your
approach to this and i just want to get
right to it all right let's do it i'm
ready we're barefoot together let's talk
about some moves and things that you can
do at home even if it's just for a few
minutes well say the kids are asleep yes
while that is while i get my workout in
while my baby is napping so let's do a
little leg workout today we're going to
get our hands in prayer and then we're
going to take our right leg sweep it
back behind the left okay curtsy lunge
and then you're just going to kick out
to the side while stabilizing on that
level we're holding it okay kelly
curtsy and kick okay for five
tighten up through that core four okay
smile on the face soften into it you got
three
two and one and that's working the inner
and outer thighs i already feel it right
it feels good and then we can go on to
our hands okay
i'll take one edge
okay
and
come on to your hands so your shoulders
are stacking over your wrist we don't
want any injuries here and your neck is
nice and neutral and then we're gonna
flex through that right foot and just
kick up to the ceiling keeping that knee
nice and bent and then pull that knee
and draw it in and almost crunch it up
so you're getting your abs involved as
well so push
are we doing it at the same to liquid
yeah we got there you got it
for three
two
and one and then we'll finish up on our
side so we'll work our inner thighs so
again no equipment you can do all of
this like in your house you really don't
need anything at all right so prop your
head in your hands and then go ahead and
glue those legs together okay feel them
up off the ground hips are nice and
square and start to scissor kick those
legs and you'll really feel the inner
thighs turn on here you got it wow look
at you go girl okay you're doing this
while talking and i'm over here like a
little out of breath but wow this feels
amazing
through that core
and you're really engaging all the
muscles doing pilates that's what i like
about it long lean beautiful muscles
without all that bulk that gets created
through weights wow well this feels
amazing and as we wrap up maybe we can
just sit here and prayer pose yeah just
be grateful for what our bodies allow us
to do and if anyone wants more
information or to follow you just tell
them where to go where to find you you
can follow me at wellness by kelly on
instagram or wellnessbykelly.com i have
a membership program that has workouts
recipes and medications thank you again
for having me jillian thank you kelly
take it for me go follow her
all right rocky i'll send it over to you
thank you